hello I'm at Conway welcome to my study
where I've been holed up most of today
trying to understand trying to get my
head round the testing numbers the
government puts together because you
might have seen this this is statistical
thority sends a very harsh letter to
Matt Hancock saying this stuff doesn't
really make any sense so I thought I'd
try and get to the bottom of it and work
out whether it did make any sense
look storage door not really but there
is some kind of slightly more owing
lessons for us there and it's worth just
having a look at the numbers it matters
by the way to know how many people have
been tested because without that you
can't get a sense of whether it's giving
a second way where people are catching
theirs what to do about it so this stuff
is really important and what's slightly
concerning is we don't really know
what's going on in the UK at the moment
let's just go through some of those
numbers you probably have seen this one
before this shows you total number of
tests as depart for Health and Social
Care reports here each day and look it's
up well do you remember that 100,000
target hooray they've got beyond that
target now number of tests is routinely
above 100,000 each day now that's kind
of arbitrary isn't it but nonetheless
they're above it does that really matter
well not really because what you're
talking about here what is kind of
underneath this line in terms of the
different bits of testing that make up
this total is very very different
there's a whole range of different kinds
of tests that are included here some of
which are you know you might call them
gold standards some of which are not
unless just kind of break that down the
gold standard bit of it is this these
are what they call pillar 1 tests see
the tests that happen in hospitals so
those who have the disease in hospitals
health workers as well this is the
testing that we have from very early on
in this epidemic and what you can see is
look it's well below that number and
it's been more or less at this kind of
level it actually peaks in kind of early
May and there's been more or less that
level ever since that's pillar one so
one bit of that line that you get from
health secretary every day then you've
got something called pillar 2 now
basically this is the other test for key
workers increasingly for all of the the
rest of us as well these are the kind of
driving tests that you can go and do and
as you can see it's quite a lot it's
about double
10:01 now those were all real tests as
we see them but still you're nowhere
near that hundred-thousand target if you
care about such things and then on top
of that you've got posted tests so these
are tests of them mailed out to people
around the country and look these blue
bits are basically the biggest part of
many of these bars this is what gets you
well above the line every day but here's
the catch we actually know how many of
these tests have actually been carried
out so there's blue bits a lot of them
haven't necessarily been carried out
haven't necessarily been returned to the
NHS and other places and so it's a bit
meaningless to include them alongside
the gold standard stuff where we do know
the answers you've got another couple of
pillars I'll just run through them
quickly got pillar three that's serology
testing the antibody testers come in
recently and pill of four those are kind
of tests that the ONS carries out to try
and work out what's going on with across
the population it's worth saying that it
again there's a difference there the ONS
tests are researched set of tests they
are not a clinical test to try and
ensure that you can save someone's life
so you're taking a load of different
things and lumping them into one number
let's add that line so now we've got to
that line and you don't get a sense of
any of that from the health secretary
every day when he's unveiling this it's
just look we're doing more tests than
ever before it's great but there are big
differences in the types of tests that
we're talking about most of all though
the biggest problem is we don't know how
many people have been tested that's
might sound a bit extraordinary but we
don't know how many people are here and
why that is because some of these tests
need to be done a number of times some
of them as I say a kind of the tests
that are mailed out they never come back
some of them including these black bits
here and the white bits there they're
kind of more gold standard stuff
some of them you need more than one test
per person because you get an order a
lot of false positives false negatives
so in many of these tests they have to
be carried out more than once sometimes
more than twice as well and so that
number isn't necessarily a number of
people who have had these tests instead
the number of people is actually a fair
bit lower
actually the 100,000 is well above here
so it
Biggers kind of a different scale in a
smaller scale and these are the number
of people who have been tested under
pillar once and again those gold
standard things and up until about a
couple of weeks ago the government every
day was saying note we're doing much
more than that we're also testing a lot
of other people and here's the total and
each day we would get these numbers
saying look we are testing routinely
kind of seventy eighty thousand people a
day through the other pillars those
other kinds of tests but here's the
funny thing about two weeks ago they
just suddenly stopped publishing it they
suddenly stopped publishing how many
people have been tested and it now turns
out when you talk to the tonton for
health about it that those numbers are
dodgy but they can rely on those numbers
so they basically withdrawn them they're
not available on their website at all I
had to kind of trawl through the
archives to actually find them and so as
far as the official numbers go this is
what we know we only know a fraction of
how many people who might have been
tested why does that matter it matters
because this is one of the crucial
metrics for whether there's going to be
a second spread it matters for whether
the disease is spreading whether people
are catching it in certain places and it
should be said you know like every
country around the world is having
trouble putting this stuff together but
many countries Belgium Singapore Hong
Kong France you know are producing a lot
of statistics granular detail about all
of this detail giving you a sense of
what's really going on with the disease
whereas in the UK we don't even know how
many people have actually been tested
for Kovach 19 you know weeks months
after this disease actually struck the
UK we're well past the peak we don't
know how many people have been tested
that's pretty important and and it kind
of underlined something that I keep
coming across which is that there's a
big difference between the data that
we're getting kind of every day for the
government the data were getting from
Department for health on Kovach 19 and
the other day so that we get every week
a little bit more kind of circumspect
data from the ons and other sources
about how many people are dying of this
disease that stuff is really good and
I'll show you a bit of that in a second
but the stuff on testing it's pretty
touchy I'm afraid and going to that ons
stuff we get every single week we get
this update on how many X
there have been so what do we say mean
by excess that's well this line here
shows the average number of people who
have died in the first kind of few
months of this year this is the average
kind of going back to 2015 an excess
deaths basically means anything above
that line so this is deaths from all
causes and it's the UK so I've got the
the ons numbers for England and Wales
but I've also got numbers from Scotland
and Northern Ireland and the big the key
thing here is this gap here really for
deaths what all causes are way above
where you would normally expect it to be
at this time of year and if you taught
up what you have there in terms of that
area you're talking about sixty one
thousand eight hundred and ninety-five
excess deaths it's a terrifying number
we're well above sixty thousand now
probably in the end we may end up
peaking at around sixty five thousand as
for what the final toll is it's very
difficult to tell because it might well
be that we have kind of a negative
number for excess deaths in the coming
weeks people who might have died either
anyway who had died a bit earlier so
trying to get a sense of of where we are
in comparison with other epidemics it's
a bit difficult but it doesn't look like
this has definitely worse than anything
we've seen
touchwood since the Spanish Influenza
worse than the Hong Kong flu at the
nineteen sixties worth than the Asian
flu in the nineteen fifties it looks
like at the moment I should say but just
looking at kind of where those deaths
are happening so this these lines here
show you excess deaths in various
different settings so you've got home
deaths at home anything above the line
is above the kind of the norm that
you've seen in recent years excess
deaths in hospitals went higher their
early peak in hospitals in terms of
people dying in hospitals it's worth
census from from all causes and then in
care homes you can see the big the
epicenter of this crisis and still there
are more excess deaths in care homes now
than there are in hospitals we are still
well above that line so we're still in
excess death territory but gratifyingly
it is coming down towards serve more
normal levels but find a point here you
know why are we looking frequently
excess deaths rather than at the
official covert nineteen statistics
whether it's from the own s or from
elsewhere is because there's a slight
kind of
something slightly unsettling here
beneath these numbers so if we take
though the care home line I showed you a
moment ago so everything beneath here is
excess deaths and when you taught it up
you're talking about 28,000 excess
deaths so in case this is the Great
Britain by the way and we don't
annoyingly don't have comparable numbers
for Northern Ireland but we've got
another Scotland England Wales and you
can see 28,000 in total but of that
about half our Kovach 19 deaths that
that block there is Kovac 19 deaths and
that still leaves unaccounted for this
block here about thirteen and thousand
seven hundred deaths just under half of
all of the excess deaths st. care homes
since the start of this epidemic aren't
really properly explained you know their
excess death so they're above the
average and yet we don't have a clear
explanation as to why they've happened
now it could well be the covert 19 was
kind of undiagnosed and many of these
cases are Cove at 19 it could be
something else it could well be that
that there are lockdown reasons people
weren't able to go to hospital and so on
but still a lot of mysteries here but as
I say with the ONS numbers we do have
more detail about what's actually
happening whereas with those numbers
from the government about testing we
just don't really have a clue to be
honest with you